what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Lauren Thompson
and today we have some insanely huge
Marvel news this news is so big that it
has the potential to change the entire
trajectory of Marvel Studios and in fact
is a good indicator that Marvel Studios
is indeed changing today's news comes as
a huge surprise but is a very good
indicator that Marvel Studios is
actively shaking things up it was
announced today that Executive Vice
President of Marvel Studios Victoria
Alonso has left a company this is coming
from The Hollywood Reporter and also is
being reported on by all of the other
major trade companies as well because
this truly is one shocking but two huge
news Victoria Alonso has been with
Marvel Studios since the very first Iron
Man film but here's what is really
interesting about this we'll talk about
this before we dive into the article but
Victoria alonso's job she was promoted
to Executive Vice President of
production and then in 2021 she was
upped to the president of physical host
production visual effects and animation
in Marvel Studios in her role she
oversaw all of Marvel's post-production
including its visual effects Works which
have been really Under Fire recently
plus not to mention actual visual
effects professionals have been
criticizing Marvel Studios as projects
recently and also visual effects workers
for Marvel Studios have recently spoken
out and kind of complained that they
were being overworked because of all of
the Disney plus projects and the new
movies that were coming out and they
weren't getting paid enough and they
weren't really getting any breaks
basically they came out and stated that
they didn't really feel that they were
treated right so this news of Victoria
Alonso leaving Marvel Studios begs a lot
of questions but let's first go over the
article to see what exactly it says now
like I said a lot of outlets are
reporting this right now but the
original article is coming from the
Hollywood Porter and they start off by
saying Victoria Alonso the long time and
high profile Marvel Studios executive
whose time with the company dates back
to the first Iron Man has left the
studio multiple sources tell The
Hollywood Reporter the reasons for the
exit are unclear but she parted ways
with Marvel Friday sources say so it
doesn't specifically say that she got
fired so we're not gonna say that it
says she exited she parted ways with
Marvel Now this comes right after the
lack of success in the box office that
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania had it
also comes after a lot of criticism
about the movie including the visual
effects which as we read she was in
charge of but this is an incredibly huge
deal for Marvel Studios because of how
important Victoria was at the studio
which means this is an incredibly huge
change for Marvel Studios she joined the
studio in 2006 as chief of visual
effects and post-production and helped
launch the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
a Coke producer on Iron Man in 2008 so
she's been with Marvel Studios since the
very beginning of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe since the birth of the MCU she
then served as a co-producer on Iron Man
2 Thor in 2011 and Captain America the
First Avenger then like I mentioned she
became an executive producer on The
Avengers film in 2012 which really did
prove and showed that a Marvel Cinematic
Universe a connected Universe where
Heroes have their own stories but then
come together on the big screen really
can actually work now again it's unclear
of why she left and we don't want to
speculate and we do want to respect her
because she did do a lot for Marvel
Studios and she was really outspoken and
a big advocate for diversity and she has
quoted stating as long as I'm at Marvel
Studios I will fight for representation
now keep in mind that Marvel Studios
right now is going through some big
changes before this even happened Disney
in general is making some really big
changes specifically with their
streaming services and the shows that
they put on those streaming services and
although we are not sure if she got
fired or she left on her own this does
indeed show that Marvel Studios is
committed to making some major changes
now according to a previous report from
the cosmic circus Marvel Studios knows
and is picked up on the fact that a lot
of fans are very let's say dissatisfied
with phase four let's face it fans have
been pretty outspoken about this
claiming that Marvel Studios is Phase 4
was pretty much just kind of described
as lukewarm now according to this report
as a preventative measure to assure
quality control Marvel Studios and
Disney themselves are reevaluating the
future releases that they have coming
out this was already happening but then
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania came
out and I didn't think the movie was
that bad I enjoyed it however it wasn't
the best movie and a lot of fans did
complain about it but make no mistake
Marvel hears everything they hear the
dissatisfied fans and so moving forward
they developed a plan to develop a sort
of creative oversight and establish more
quality control moving forward this
could be a part of that plan getting
somebody new to oversee the visual
effects and quality control and
post-production so this could be a very
big sign that Marvel Studios and Disney
are getting extremely serious with
changing the way that they do things now
there have been some visual effects
artists out there who have actually said
that they are scared of Victoria Alonso
one even said this the main one that
everyone's quite scared of is Victoria
Alonso she is known in the industry as a
king maker if she likes you you are
going to get work and move up in the
industry if you have pissed her off in
any way you're going to get frozen out
so there are a lot of factors here that
could come into play on why Victoria
Alonso is no longer with Marvel Studios
especially like I mentioned after all of
the visual effects artists have come out
and complained recently and both Marvel
Studios as president Kevin feige and
Disney CEO Bob Iger have come out and
stated yes they are indeed changing they
are trying to get better they are trying
to focus on quality over quantity and
what this really means is that they
realize that they are lacking quality
right now that they have lack quality
over the past few years with phase 4
which is great it's great that they
realize that and it's great that they
realize that they need to kind of pump
the brakes and produce less content and
Kevin feige even mentioned that he hates
that word content but basically they're
going to produce less movies less shows
per year and have the ones that they do
release be really really good basically
as we've talked about on the channel
before they're going to get back to what
they did with phase one through three
and while we've been following their
journey and while Executives have been
speaking up stating that they are indeed
making some changes this comes as the
biggest shock so far whether she
resigned on her own because it just
wasn't working out with Marvel Studios
and the projects that they were doing or
perhaps maybe there were some
disagreements about what their future
plans were or if she was fired because
her vision simply didn't line up with
Kevin feige's Vision about what they
plan to do in the future either way
Marvel Studios is looking to get better
and this is a big change that could
potentially actually push them further
along the path and now they have a role
to fill and make no mistake they're
going to definitely think long and hard
about who should take over this new
position nothing against Victoria Alonso
but this does seem to put Marvel Studios
in a pretty good position if they want
better visual effects quality control
bringing somebody in that's new that has
fresh ideas and that is maybe more
related to visual effects on their own
personal career that they've had so far
is a pretty good move so I think this
news comes as an actual pretty good sign
that Marvel Studios is going to be
improving and hopefully pretty soon but
of course we acknowledge that Victoria
Alonso did a lot of great things for
Marvel Studios and she was there since
the birth of the MCU with Iron Man she's
done a lot of great things for Marvel
Studios and we definitely thank her for
the time that she spent at Marvel
Studios and of course if we hear
anything else about why she is no longer
with Marvel Studios we'll do an update
video so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest MCU news please
don't forget to like the video and you
can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof